u.s and russian leaders speak but reach
no breakthrough on ukraine so is
diplomacy reaching a dead end
why is the crisis proving so hard to
solve this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the show i'm sami
zaydan in doha now the latest diplomatic
attempt between the united states and
russia to resolve tensions over ukraine
has achieved apparently nothing
presidents putin and biden exchanged
warnings and concerns over the phone but
little else meanwhile military activity
continues on both sides moscow has been
massing troops in russia and belarus
near the border with ukraine
and the buildup is raising fears an
invasion is imminent ukraine is
receiving western support its biggest
ally the us is sending 200 million
dollars worth of military aid including
armor-penetrating missiles and
ammunition
the french presidency says russia's
given no indication of an invasion of
ukraine
that came out of a conversation between
the french and russian presidents
emmanuel macron spoke again with
vladimir putin by phone on saturday
after his visit to moscow last week
putin told macron nato members had
failed to respond to russia's security
demands macron has also been in touch
with german chancellor olaf schultz and
ukraine's president vladimir zaninsky to
promote stability in europe
more countries are telling their
citizens in ukraine to leave immediately
australia has evacuated staff from its
embassy in kiev the united states warned
it will not evacuate anyone if war broke
out and has reduced its diplomatic
mission britain and canada are doing the
same ukraine called those moves
premature though
all right let's bring in our guests into
the show we have joining us from moscow
pavel falgenhauer he's a defense and
military analyst and a columnist at
novia gazetta in chicago matthew breiser
is senior fellow at the atlantic council
and a former diplomat and national
security official at the white house
and in oslo glenn diesen is professor of
international relations at the
university of southeastern norway and
editor of russia in global affairs
welcome to you all if i could start them
with pavel does the outcome of the
latest biden putin phone call indicate
that perhaps diplomacy is heading
towards a dead end
uh well apparently there was no serious
progress there it was of course a number
of phone calls
there was also
secretary blinken talking to lavrov and
and the american defense secretary
talking to shoigu and also um
general gerasim of chief of general
staff
talking to general mili so there's a
flurry of
phone calls also involving the french
president the
british who were also involved and up to
now no big progress happening but of
course it's better to talk
not than not to talk
uh but the situation is extremely tense
and getting worse and the only good news
most likely is
that it will be somehow resolved in a
week or
two
because the present
very high state of readiness cannot
continue indefinitely pavel tell me why
you think it might be resolved in a week
or two in particular
uh well i say the
super high state of readiness of the
russian military cannot continue
indefinitely they'll have to step down
or go into action
and
there have been movements of
for
equipment
long distance from the far east to
the polish border from uh the far east
to the mediterranean from the northern
seas to again black sea and
mediterranean so these
ships will have to return these troops
will have to return
everyone will have to step down in the
in several weeks maybe in march for sure
uh so such a decision should come
technically much earlier it's touch or
go it's either go or it's a it's a stand
down so all right matthew step down or
step out or step up but something's got
to happen
but apparently not on the diplomatic
front was the biden putin phone call
perhaps one of the last shots for
diplomacy
well it depends on how you look at
diplomacy i mean because a war is the
continuation of politics by other means
we always have to keep in mind that the
objective in this case of the one who's
provoked the conference president uh the
the crisis president putin is political
so his political goals as we can clearly
see now are to prevent ukraine from ever
joining nato to destabilizing ukraine
but also in the bigger sense it's to
it's to push back uh nato's influence in
eastern europe and restore a sense of
russian greatness in europe so those are
political goals and president putin has
used to chosen to use the threat of
military force and the threat of a
full-scale invasion to pursue those
goals through diplomacy
diplomacy is happening and so uh
president putin has not chosen yet
to employ these massive capabilities
that he has deployed and so i would
argue that diplomacy has succeeded so
far in deterring president putin from
invading ukraine again and diplomacy has
succeeded precisely because nato has
maintained a united front and has said
the costs of an invasion of another
invasion will be high will be painful
you don't want to do this and i think
that has given president putin pause had
there been no united front as under the
obama administration of nato had there
been no clear sign of high costs that
would be imposed for invasion of uh
crimea and of donbass
in this case we would have seen the
troop movements already by russia what
will happen in the next couple of weeks
that's going to be up to president
that's interesting
let me jump in here
matthew and ask pavel to comment on that
do you agree with that analysis pavel
that had it not been for the united
front demonstrated by the us and its
allies that perhaps we would have
already seen
a russian invasion of ukraine or further
russian invasion of ukraine now
well you maybe we don't know i mean it's
like you know in the summer of 1914
before the war began there was lots of
diplomacy and phone calls and you could
say that the phone calls prevented the
war but actually they didn't
so we're saying
we should have to might mean see a real
uh step down of forces before uh we can
actually talk about the success of
diplomacy right all right matthew i
interrupted you so i'm gonna let you
finish your thought before we bring in
glenn
thanks tammy so i was just saying that
you know what will happen in the next
few weeks depends upon whether or not
nato is able to maintain this united
stands this solidarity in demonstrating
how high the costs could be of an
invasion of a re-invasion and so you
know i'm i'm a little bit concerned that
in
recent days it's become clear that uh
many of the us's european allies are
saying they're not in favor of severe
the most severe economic countermeasures
such as uh unplugging russia from swift
from the international electronic
payment system i think president putin
is looking that as a sign that he can
turn up the pressure
and play on the fear that germany and
france and other big nato member states
have
of another war in europe president putin
is really effective at using the threat
of force to frighten uh the us's
european allies now all of this is
coming after a period of intense
diplomacy lately glenn we've had
uh boris johnson emmanuel macron anthony
blinken all visiting kiev or moscow or
perhaps even both
what is it achieved so far for sure i
mean we were kind of talking already
about has it achieved
stopping an invasion that might have
already taken place but what do we know
it has achieved for sure so far
well i think something obviously has
been achieved with these discussions
again for russia the main objective is
for
is well is twofold first to resolve the
internal crisis in ukraine which means
it has to pressure the west to
to push ukraine towards actually abiding
by the minsk two agreements so again
kiev promised uh that it would engage
with ombuds and granted some autonomy
the u.s has not uh pushed the ukraine to
abide by this agreement instead they're
pumping in weapons which could enable
kiev to take back this region by force
so this is one of the things russia's
attempting to deter and also pressure
the west to actually follow through with
this agreement the second is on the
regional level which is
uh which is your pan-european security
as we know throughout the 1990s and you
know all all the osse osce partners
agreed
to the principle of indivisible security
so one side shouldn't expand or secure
it at the expense of other but again
during those days we could ignore it
because russia was weak but now
obviously russia is not weak anymore and
it's demanding very clear security
guarantees that well effectively us in
nato abides by the agreements that we
have signed so i think that given that
we're actually talking about this which
we haven't done
at all
over many years it suggests that there's
already some progress
um but um otherwise i would
disagree to some extent with the former
person speaking here because i think the
fact that nato is not united i think
that's actually can be a positive thing
because
we see that a lot of the continental
europeans are telling the russians that
well maybe we can come to an agreement
uh maybe we can you know push ukraine to
abide by this agreement maybe we can
have pan-european security deals and
this is i think what's preventing uh war
from happening because russia obviously
has no
a lot to lose from an invasion it
doesn't want to use force but it has red
lines and at the moment so far i would
say france germany
the fact that these countries are not
pushing or following the us line on this
i think that's actually yeah preventing
war from occurring
interesting some of your comments make
us think back to 1962 and of course this
is not the first time we've seen the us
in a position of
trying to convince russia to back down
in a military confrontation at the
height of the cold war you'll recall the
cuban missile crisis president john
kennedy urging where he was urged rather
by his advisers to invade cuba after the
discovery of soviet nuclear missile
installations there but kennedy rejected
that in what became known as the cuban
missile crisis and at the beginning of
the 13 days standoff kennedy ordered a
naval blockade of cuba to prevent soviet
reinforcements and demanded moscow
remove the weapons kennedy then warned
cuba's leader fidel castro of the
dangers his people were facing the
prospect of airstrikes to destroy the
sites followed by an invasion that could
lead to the deaths of thousands
now while war seemed inevitable at one
point kennedy's choice of diplomatic
pressure over military action eventually
brought both sides together to make
concessions saving both countries
and the rest of the world
from all-out nuclear war
now i'm wondering when we look back at
that pavel
why
is it proving so hard this time to have
that kind of deal
between the two sides where they come to
some understanding to pull back forces
from areas close to each other's borders
well there it also didn't happen uh in a
fortnight it was a
process of
threats and counter threats and in the
end
of the sides decided to step down from
the from the brink uh of course there
were other there was another similar
crisis that's in 73 uh during the in the
end of the arab-israeli war when russia
was prepared uh
there were sev hours left or before
a number of russian airborne divisions
should have landed in egypt together
with nuclear weapons to fight the
israelis and the americans
lifted the defcon level and
decided to also send the same 82
division
airborne that's now deploying in poland
was prepared to deploy to israel to
fight the russians and there was
kissinger having this uh
shuttle diplomacy that moros
secured an agreement an agreement that
was held holding for a long time like in
the cuban crisis there was an agreement
that actually was standing there for
decades after it was reached that's what
we should be looking now for not just
simply as a
kind of tactical de-escalation for so
for several weeks or several months but
for an agreement that will actually
prevent
this particular crisis from recreating
somewhere in the summer
uh you need someone who's going to be
working on such an agreement that should
be uh
effective uh
shuttle diplomacy well president macron
tried to do that apparently he's not
well equipped for it because france
can't pressurize no one even ukraine
into doing what ukraine does not want to
do
and can't pressurize russian can't
pressurize the united states so you need
someone who can extend that's an
important point that's an important
point let me jump in here because that's
kind of related to what glenn was saying
a moment ago and let me take this
question then to glenn and say is the
world perhaps today a different place
than in 1962 or during the arab-israeli
conflicts
where
as
you've been saying glenn
basically nato isn't as united as it was
before and also perhaps russia is not as
strong as it was during the peak of the
cold war under the days of the soviet
union is there perhaps less
of
of an incentive because of of that
situation for both sides to quickly
reach a resolution
well obviously i mean at the moment uh
russia is obviously much much weaker
than what the soviet union was uh but
that also means that in europe this uh
threat of uh
of russia is not it's not as severe as
it used to be so this idea that you know
russia wants to restore the soviet union
or invade western europe it's you know
this thing's country will be taken that
seriously and you also see by the
expenditure
um the military expenditures of the
europeans they don't spend that much on
weapons simply because
they don't see russia being this much uh
this big of a threat and also there's
more empathy now towards uh towards this
idea of russia that
that of course they also have the right
for security and if if they're denied
security then they will have to respond
in a way which deny which undermines the
security of the europeans matthew let me
jump in okay would perhaps ukrainians
have a different perspective who've seen
of course the eastern part of their
country and don bass go through um an
invasion what they would see as a
russian invasion
well i i think that many in ukraine see
the countries to be somewhat of a bit of
a pawn because we keep saying that the
u.s supports ukraine but but let's be
honest what happened when nato offered
ukraine nato membership future
membership in 2008 only 20 of ukrainians
wanted it they they had a free and open
election where they elected uh
yanukovych who would put it into law
that ukraine should be an independent
country he was removed in a coup which
did not have democratic support and and
thereafter they have been you know
feared to become like a staging ground
for the u.s
aggression against russia so so i think
many in ukraine see themselves as being
effectively yeah used as a pawn between
the us and russia so i
uh so i i do think
that some of this analogy of course
works but in terms of the cuban missile
crisis this is obviously reversed
because this time
yeah all right let me give matthew
because matthew was looking to uh to get
in there so go ahead yeah
yeah um i think that the the the point
you made sami earlier about um you know
then during the cuban mr crisis
president kennedy decided not to use
force and not to follow up and those who
were threatening to use force is
actually completely
uh inappropriate here it is vladimir
putin that is threatening to use force
he is threatening to kill tens of
thousands of people
based on a false interpretation a lie
about nato threatening russia how in the
world in this crisis is nato threatening
russia is when the united states and its
allies send troops to to nato member
states to say if russia moves into our
countries we will respond militarily but
as biden has said if putin again invades
ukraine we will respond not with a
single soldier on the ground but with
economic sanctions how is that the
threat to use force in addition in
countries let me jump in as i play
devil's advocate here matthew and flip
the hat now
and look at things from the russian
perspective could they not see things
from the same perspective that the us
saw things in 1962 and say well by
virtue of considering to to admit
ukraine into nato that would allow
nato forces to be much too close to the
russian
heartland
no of course not because russia has
already agreed that
it both not only in the 1975 helsinki
final act but in subsequent agreements
to which mr diesen um referred a that it
will not threaten to use military force
uh against any european or osce member
state assembling 130 000 troops
surrounding a oecd member state on three
sides that is clearly a violation of
that 1975 commitment that was
subsequently reflected in many other of
uh international commitments of russia
not to mention the 1994 budapest
memorandum when russia pledged to
respect ukraine's territorial integrity
if ukraine gave up its nuclear weapons
so um
president putin knows that russia is a
defensive alliance it has only um called
into called into force article 5 which
calls for collective defense in one
instance
after the united states was attacked on
september 11th nato has no plans no
doctrine no operational plans to attack
russian forces anywhere outside of
nato's own space so this is a canard
these are russian kremlin talking points
that uh
nato is violating these international
agreements that russia is in sharp
breach of and that there's any threat to
use force against russia there is a
threat to use force
for self-defense of nato not to attack
russia on russian territory all right
let's uh turn things around go to pavel
in moscow pavel you said maybe a week or
two if war doesn't break out
that doesn't necessarily mean the end of
this diplomatic crisis does it will we
witness a period of perhaps escalating
diplomatic and military tensions and
perhaps all around the world
yes we're seeing that happening right
now i mean and actually last year there
was
massive russian exercises and there was
a landing of ten thousand men two hours
from air and sea but it happened not on
ukrainian territory but in crimea so
that was a dry run now we are against
the more western the same waters and
it's already much bigger than ukraine
and that's the message coming from
moscow that this is a a serious security
crisis and it's more important and we
just saw several hours ago there was an
incident close to the curio islands when
apparently an american submarine and a
russian anti-submarine frigate
came at apparently maybe even two shots
maybe not it's not clear but maybe the
bombs were dropped and of course the
russia is running right now a massive
exercise in the sea of ahotsk in the sea
of ocos the so-called
bastion or
fortress where russia hides its
strategic nuclear submarines from where
they can shoot
intercontinental missiles at america and
they have to defend them against
american attack submarines
and also there's a standoff developing
between american and nato allied
aircraft carriers in the eastern
mediterranean and a big russian naval
force gathering there so there can be
outside of ukraine there's no ukrainians
in the pacific and no ukrainian forces
in the mediterranean but so but there
could be actually skirmishes between
in the air and on the sea and under the
sea between direct american and russian
uh military which could lead to a global
war maybe nuclear war very quickly
all right i can see
there should be some way to defuse this
and find the kind of good pro quo i
think everyone would agree on that last
bit there should be a way to diffuse it
i think we've got a brief minute left
let me give it if i may to glenn and
glenn
looking at the big picture of all this
is this a readjustment of the balance of
power since the strength and the unity
of both what was the soviet union today
russia and
and on the west on the other hand
that balance of power is different today
obviously and i think that's what we're
seeing now it's an adjustment because
unipolar order already came to an end
and there's an efforts now to adjust to
this multipolar system and this
transition has not been done uh properly
yet and this is also some of the
explains a lot of actions by the united
states so for example uh
is that cause for us to to be optimistic
that humanity will not allow annihilate
itself
no not not necessarily use the analogy
of uh all the historical analogy of the
cuban missile crisis and you have to
remember that at that point uh kennedy
they kept it a secret to the american
public that actually made a compromise
with the soviets so there's not always
and
this idea that the compromise is seen as
a weakness or appeasement as we hear
every time
someone suggests a compromise with
russia i think uh yeah it gives reason
for
being very pessimistic but again i think
more countries now especially germany
and france are starting to realize that
yeah some compromise will have to be
found in order to avoid the castostrophe
because again from for russia this is
seen as a red line which they can't pack
away from so there has to be
some some
change in the mentality because uh this
this order we had for the past 30 years
where the west simply dictates and
nothing russia can do it's i think it's
painful
for the western to accept that this area
has come to an end but uh
i think this makes compromise all the
more difficult as well
all right it's been a great discussion
unfortunately we're going to have to
leave it there for now let's thank our
guests very much for
their contributions
pavel matthew and glenn
and thank you two for watching you can
see the show again anytime by visiting
our website
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
head over to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter our handle is at aj inside
story from me sami zaydan and the whole
team here in delhi for now it's goodbye